we ain't scared of nobody though no I'm
gonna go I'm gonna go and recruit like
the best guys I can that can get get my
hands on that I can afford for my team
that's the thing you help a lot of guys
out too yeah especially at the gym
you're at there's some Savages yeah yeah
I'm gonna be going to a lot of other
different gyms and stuff too just
recruiting my team get like a good tight
team you know I'll tell you right now
good luck recruiting anyone to beat
Frank man's daughter I know just just
don't
yeah she already Savage super Savage
what weight class is she I just have to
get them away uh was she 220 no way
she's two no she's tiny now yeah